i was wrong about the iphone 10s battery
case
i was wrong in saying that it was only
369 milliamps
but the thing that i was most wrong
about was the fact that i said that i
didn't need this
i do need it before we get into why i
love this thing so much a huge thank you
to lastpass for sponsoring this video
you guys have been so incredible and
i've been using lastpass for quite a
while now what i love about lastpass is
not only do they keep all of my
passwords safe and secure but they can
also create
very unique passwords for every one of
my accounts lastpass will save all of
your usernames and passwords so anytime
you need to log in
if it's on your phone on your computer
it makes it super simple
it works on ios android mac os windows
basically anything that you need to log
into it'll remember all of those things
and log you in
instantly so you don't have to remember
all of your passwords or write them down
or lose them
everything will be safe and secure they
also have this other cool thing
it'll give you password breach alerts
it'll let you know if that password that
you're using is not secure any longer so
huge thank you to lastpass for
sponsoring this video again i'll put a
link in the description to lastpass if
you guys want to check it out
and now let's talk about this case
according to this verge article instead
of using a single large cell like the
iphone 7 battery case
apple is actually using two battery
cells wired in a series which keeps the
net amperage
the same but lets it boost the voltage
to 8.7 volts which is higher than the
previous 3.8 volts so like i was saying
this case has been unbelievably
just shockingly way better than i
thought it was gonna be i was kind of
skeptical when i first did the unboxing
i was like uh
okay it's just another case for my phone
that charges the battery the best
example that kind of really solidified
how much i love this is the other day
when i was traveling back to los angeles
from pennsylvania i got up
super early on the east coast i think it
was like 5am there packed
got to the airport traveled was on my
phone all day long
during the flight get back home do
whatever it is i have to do
and by the time i went to bed like i
still actually had battery left
and it was kind of shocking because
before i would always feel like i was
tethered
to a battery device like i would always
constantly have something with me i was
always
charging my phone i felt like and with
this my phone was always charged i
didn't have to worry about anything
i was so impressed with this thing that
i'm making a follow-up video i've said
so many great things about this case
that my sister was like well i need to
get one too
after this video i'm gonna go surprise
her with this i also love that it kind
of has this little ridge
and i did say that it was heavy but now
i'm so used to it i never drop my phone
anymore because i'm able to just kind of
hold on to it too
so it's been great when i'm filming or
taking pictures sometimes when i'm using
the osmo pocket
actually here's a video when i was
playing topgolf not too long ago and
it was raining so not only did the case
get wet but my phone got what and the
osmo pocket
oh man i may have
missed
but because this was a little bit
thicker it sort of acted as a little bit
more of a tripod so the osmo here the
phone here
i don't really think that this is that
water resistant but it resisted
it's still working perfectly so i guess
that's
proof and test enough that it still is
working
even after getting wet i do want to go
give this to jenna so we'll have to
surprise her after this video
i would love to hear from you guys
though have you used battery packs
before have you used this one
are you as pleasantly surprised as i am
how great this is or is this just kind
of a new thing for me because i'm
not used to using battery packs so let's
take a look here so
my smart battery case currently is at 0
it is now
804 p.m and my phone is at 90
that's unheard of i haven't charged my
phone all day technically
it's been charging sort of all day but
you know what i mean
it's just crazy to see that it is this
late and my phone still has charge
it's shocking to me i mean the iphone
10s max already has really great battery
life i thought
so i thought this was something that i
wouldn't need and now it's something
that i just can't even live without
so long story long video short now that
i've been using this for a few weeks i
just kind of retract anything that i
said
previously about not needing this
because this has made such a huge
difference because this is all i need i
don't need to worry about having an
extra charger
i still always have an extra charger
with me i'm just paranoid and i also
have other things that i need to charge
like the osmo pocket and like my gopro
and i've been using this massive nimble
charger this thing is incredible so when
i'm also traveling sometimes flights
don't have
plugs or outlets i've been using this to
charge my macbook the macbook can charge
with usbc the only downside is it
doesn't actually charge the computer but
it does keep it alive so what i do
is when my macbook is 50 i plug it into
the nimble charger
and that will give me like a couple
extra hours and then once the nimble
charger dies
then i just continue using the rest of
my battery life
and then that's that's my day basically
i've also been using it on my ipad pro
i've been using my ipad pro so much more
i've been getting into procreate so it's
been really fun
kind of going in and just doing like
some illustrations lots of paintings so
it's been really fun kind of using that
sort of an alternative to my computer
when i don't have to edit videos
ugh i have so much i feel like i want to
talk to you guys about like i've been
loving my new server like everything is
just sort of coming together
i'm so looking forward to doing kind of
my office renovation i know you guys
were like didn't you
just redo your office i feel like your
office is always sort of under
construction
yes it is always under construction and
that's because
for me when something i feel like gets
to the peak perfection that i think that
it is perfect
it's time to destroy that and start over
because if that's as high as you can get
and that's the level of achievement
there's no point in continuing
you need to tear it down and start over
it's probably not
the most logical thing but for me that's
how i operate
so welcome to the inner workings of my
mind
i also want to say a huge shout out to
the ij army members if you guys don't
know i did
start a membership thing on my channel
you guys actually were making some
decisions on what emojis you'd like to
see
making decisions on which thumbnails you
guys like and i'm not sure the future of
that
is kind of up in the air it's like what
do you guys like what do you want to see
that is the beauty of youtube and this
community and just
the internet in general you guys
actually help create and make decisions
about the content that i create so it's
really
just so fun and i think you guys are all
incredible and
i think that was all i wanted to talk
about i really just wanted to focus on
this i have so many updates that i want
to just
talk about i just don't even know where
to start i'm flustered
i have got a surprise for you i'm scared
you're like go stand right there i'm
like why
so the thing is i told jenna was like
remind me that i have a surprise for you
the surprise is should i close my eyes
are you gonna do something to make no
here put this in your hand see if you
can guess what it is
it's rubbery oh it's a phone case yeah
but what kind
i open my eyes oh this is oh this is not
the battery charger
battery charger one so i've non stopped
been talking about how much i love this
thing and
i was like oh maybe i should buy one for
myself but i said well girl guess what
stick your phone in there well
so oh i found it okay your pants
i have maybe i'll take this back
i forgot what phone i have it's
basically that's good it'll look nice in
there
this thing has been so great i also
charged it for you so wait wait
so you're supposed to do it you insert
here like at the top
slide it in that makes way more sense
than what i was trying to do
another thing that i absolutely love
about charging
it is charging it so if you oh
so i guess maybe by charging maybe like
so you didn't charge it
maybe i didn't charge it i thought that
i did get your face in there
so so you can um you can see the the
battery life i know how to do that
yeah so my smart battery case is 0 i
thought i charged it for you but i
actually charged my own does this work
with
wireless does that's what i was getting
at this also charges wireless so it
basically just acts like
a i like it it's cool a case that
targets like a nice nice extra grip too
because i'm
reckless with these things so enjoy
so this is dead i appreciate it thank
you we're in a match
do you want me to paint wait for it no
it's a gift your nails are white mine
are black
oh fashions
i have nothing else to add to this video
thank you enjoy your gift
thank you mine now bye you guys want a
hug or something no
it's okay
[Music]
you